[Applause]
[Music]
are people becoming obsolete a giant
electronic brain is started cogitating
at the University of Pennsylvania it's
made of vacuum tubes like your radio and
it can add up a column of figures a yard
long in a second it's the world's first
electronic computer right now it's
solving mathematical problems for the US
Army but who knows someday a machine
like this may check up on your income
tax do you believe that the world's
first electronic computer called eniac
was built in America in the Autumn of
1945 many people are convinced that this
is a historical fact but it isn't in
fact the world's first computer had
already been working successfully 5
years earlier in 1940 in Germany what's
more a prototype of this machine was
built in
1938 sounds incredible like a German
space base on the moon but it's no
fantasy let's find out how events
unfolded this video was created by suub
the verification platform we make the
digital world people friendly yet
[Music]
secure the Second World War Began on
September the 1st
1939 the German Army was fighting in
Poland
I therefore resolve to speak to Poland
in the same language in which Poland has
addressed
us Conrad Ernst uto Zeus a young berin
working as an engineer at the hensill
aircraft Factory in scheld was drafted
to the front Conrad Zeus was born in
Berlin into the family of a post office
clerk in 1928 he enrolled at the
Technical University of Berlin in the
faculty of engineering and architecture
but found this profession boring he
graduated as a civil engineer in
1935 civil engineers carried out a huge
number of mathematical calculations
using large books with tables of figures
Zeus found it too tedious and dreamed of
automating this process to realize his
dream Zeus began to design a mechanical
calculator to help him in his
engineering
work adding machines existed before this
but Zeus's machine was
unusual firstly it worked in the binary
number system like modern computers it
was a floating Point binary mechanical
calculator no one had done this before a
mechanical arithmometer worked with a
decimal number system a machine that
performed mathematical operations in
binary showed the effectiveness of this
principle which is now used in all
modern
computers secondly it could read
instructions from a punched tape Zoom
used 355 mm Celluloid film as the punch
tape making holes in it with an oil this
was the first time in history that punch
tape was used to store data now the
principle of a separately stored program
where the program exists separately from
the computer on some physical medium
seems obvious but it was a real
Discovery in
1939 and it was Conrad Zeus who invented
it the zed1 consisted of different
functional units the input unit the
output unit the memory units and the
addition unit each of these units was
built for a specific purpose and all
units were connected the machine
contained a complex set of metal plates
Each of which could be moved in a
strictly defined Direction the movement
of some of the plates which indicated
the values of the calculated quantities
and the mathematical operation to be
performed caused the movement of a
number of other plates which changed the
register of binary numbers and
remembered the intermediate
result the data obtained in this way
could then be used to perform other
Transformations and so it was born the
first programmable computer in history
named
[Music]
zed1 Conrad Zeus began assembling it in
1936 in the living room of his parents'
house at the same time he worked as a
design engineer at the henel aircraft
Factory near
Berlin in 1938 the Assembly of the zed1
was complete
but it was too soon to celebrate for
Zeus as the machine broke down too often
because it had very complicated design
and insufficient mechanical Precision
the monster was made up of 30,000 parts
so it was very difficult to repair from
an objective point of view the Practical
value of this device was rather small
perhaps its only useful feature is the
ability to store instructions on punch
tape but the logic of automatic
calculations in a binary system
developed by Zo
which proved the fundamental possibility
of creating programmable computers that
work directly with binary code was of
great scientific
value the young inventor planned to
perfect his calculator but this plan was
not to be because he was called to the
front even though the 1940s was a long
time ago a significant proportion of the
world's population do suffer from
digital exclusion in many regions
especially in Emerging Markets digital
access really isn't equal hi my name is
Lucas back once again from suup so now
following this lots of people can't
really enjoy full digital rights simply
because of where they come from they
come from these gray areas and in such
cases companies often ignore the users
personal characteristics focusing
instead on the region this eventually
leads to companies losing out on
potential customers or Partners so to
promote inclusiveness and find
opportunities in New Markets businesses
should conduct fair and thorough checks
to do so it is essential to understand
the specifics of each region we at suub
can help with this verifying users from
all over the world offering our
expertise in a wide range of documents
and languages we can also adapt to
Regional specifics enabling customers to
create detailed verification Journeys
through what we call the suub workflow
Builder this allows companies to set up
a custom verification workflow based on
various parameters such as country of
citizenship all of this can then be done
with no code to learn more about this
solution and suub how we can help the
user verification onboarding process
easier please click the link in the
description
below once in the Army Zeus managed to
convince the command that he would be of
more use to his country by continuing
his
research amazingly he was allowed to
return to his engineering work and in
1939 he began developing a new version
of the computer which he called the
zed2 Zeus decided decided to make this
computer half mechanical and half
electronic using telephone Rays as logic
elements to work on the electronic part
of the machine Zeus recruited his friend
the electronics engineer helmet Shrea
Shrea suggested using vacuum tubes as
the basis for a computer but Zeus
abandoned this idea because the tubes
were
unreliable if this computer had been
built on vacuum tubes it would have
broken down every 20 hours like lakum at
eniac which ran on these elements
in addition the vacuum tubes get very
warm during operation and they attract
insects hence the term bug which
originally didn't mean a bug in the code
but a moth that shorted out the context
on the circuit board Zeus and Shreya
gave a lecture at the Technical
University of Berlin in which they
outlined the essence of their project
but the idea of building a computer from
several thousand electronic components
aroused suspicion in the audience and
was considered impractical at the time
the most complex electronic circuits
consisted of no more than a 100
elements the friends knew the scientists
were wrong and decided to continue their
work anyway on their own free time with
their own money and at their own
risk work was completed in
1940 the machine took up several rooms
in Zeus's parents' house in September
the inventors presented the computer to
the commission of the German aerodynamic
Research Institute the commission was
literally Amazed by the capabilities of
the computer and allocated funding to
complete the project the computer was
taken to the aircraft Factory and used
to calculate aerodynamic corrections to
the wings of flying
bombs unlike the zed1 the zed2 Ed 16bit
fixed Point arithmetic instead of 22-bit
floating
point the arithmetic and control logic
was implemented using 600 electrical
relay circuits weighing over
600 the computer had 64 words of memory
the weight of the computer was 300 kg or
660 lb and the average calculation speed
was 0.8 seconds for an additional
operation in comparison ANC weighed 30
tons but it was
faster ANC was capable of Performing 357
multiplication operations or 5,000
additional operations per second in 1941
Zeus founded a company Zeus appar at
construction the world's first
commercial computer company long before
DEC and other Giants of the IT industry
Zeus rented a workshop opposite his
parents house to assemble his
computers in May 1941 Conrad Zeus
presented a computer he had built in his
Workshop the
zed3 the zed3 was a 22-bit binary
floating points mechanical electronic
calculator programmable with loops but
without conditional jumps with memory
and an arithmetic unit based on
Telephone
relays Zeus obtained the telephone
relays mainly by dismantling discarded
telephone
equipment the Z3 was built with 2,000
relays implementing a 22-bit word length
that operated at a clock frequency of
about 5 to 10 Herz the Z3 floating point
was improved over that of the zed1 in
that it implemented exception handling
the exceptional values plus infinity
minus infinity and undefined could be
generated and passed through
operations if we compare this machine
with ANC whose memory capacity was 20
number words the Zeus computer had a
larg memory capacity 64 words with a
length of 22 bits but less computational
performance the clock frequency of the
ENC was much higher 100 khz compared to
the Z 3's 5 to 10
Herz architecturally however ENC was a
decimal machine while the Z3 was a
binary like all the modern
computers it was the first machine in
human history to have independently
stored programs that could be recorded
on punch
tape development of the Z3 computer was
partly funded by the government
sponsored German Research Institute for
Aviation to automate its extensive
calculations this machine worked at the
henell factory to calculate the HS 293
and HS 294 guided missiles developed by
the German military between 1941 and in
1945 which were the forerunners of the
modern cruise
missile in 1942 Conrad Zeus began
developing a successor to the zed3
called the zed4 an even more advanced
computer based on Telephone relays this
computer already had 1,24 memory
registers for storing 22-bit words and a
powerful relay based processor that
could perform binary number conversions
at high speed it used punched program
tapes which made programming and correct
programs easy numbers and digits were
entered and output in decimal floating
point but the computer worked internally
in
binary the machine had a large
repertoire of instructions including
square root Max Min and sign conditional
checks included checks for Infinity the
machine had a conditional Branch
facility added and could print on a
Mercedes
typewriter this way Zeus was the first
who invented the printer and was able to
attach it to a
computer the machine had a large
repertoire of instructions the Prototype
of the programming
language Zeus later developed the
world's first fully-fledged programming
language for his computers which he
called planker cool plan calculus this
language had a major influence on the
future syntax of alol Zeus tried to get
funding for his company from the German
government but his application was
rejected as strategically unimportant
because the government believed that
Germany would achieve world domination
before the machine was built
[Music]
[Applause]
the war progressed rapidly and success
at the front inspired optimism in
Germany but history took a different
turn in 1943 the Allies began Air Raids
on Berlin Zeus's workshop at methfessel
7 and his parents' house were completely
destroyed in an Allied air raid In late
1943 the zed1 zed2 and zed3 computers as
well as the documentation were buried
under the ruins forever this effectively
ended the possibility of further
research much later these computers were
restored from the sketchy drawings that
remained these machines are now on
display in German museums but the
unfinished Zed 4 which Zeus built in a
new workshop at Orion St 6 remained
intact in 1945 the Russian and Allied
armies approached Berlin after the war
Zeus lived in poverty for several years
and was unable to finished work on the
zed4 computer in 1949 the Swiss
mathematician Edward stifel visited Zeus
when stifel formulated a differential
equation as a test Zeus immediately
programmed and solved it on the zed4
stifel was so impressed that he bought
the computer for his newly founded
Institute for Applied Mathematics in
Zurich at the time it was the only
working digital computer in Central
Europe the zed4 worked there until
1950 after selling some of his patent to
IBM Zeus saved some money and resumed
his business of building commercial
computers founding the company Zeus
kg this company built many computers
labeled Zed through to zed 43 including
the z22 the first computer with a memory
based on magnetic
[Music]
storage in the 1970s however Zeus's
computers could not not compete with IBM
and DEC machines and his company ceased
to exist
independently it was taken over by
another company which eventually became
part of the Seaman
group Conrad Ernst Oto Zeus died of a
heart attack on 18th of December
1995 Zeus never became a member of the
Nazi party but some people criticized
him for working for the Nazis during the
war much later he said that his question
was similar to gut's fa question that
scientists and Engineers sometimes had
to choose between doing their work for
military interests or not working at all
computer technology like atomic energy
is first and foremost a scientific
achievement that can be used both for
peaceful purposes and to make
[Music]
weapons everything depends on Whose
hands these Technologies fall into it's
rumored that Zeus was invited to work in
America after the war but he refused
because he wanted to develop computer
technology in his own country
his dream was to make computers in
Germany as good as those in the United
States Zeus was a true Pioneer in the
field of computer science and his death
marked the end of another era in the
development of European Information
Technology it could be said that Zeus
like the computer enthusiasts of the
1970s started building his computer in
his garage just like Steve Jobs did yes
he was Steve Jobs but only in
1936 maybe that's why his company didn't
become apple he invented computers too
early in life the world wasn't ready for
[Music]
it